[Music]
when i was a kid i used to love to make
prank phone calls a reoccurring
character i had was
the very innocent
international
man foreign man can you say foreigner
you can say foreign man foreigner all of
a sudden sounds yeah we're just
disparaging anyway he was a guy who's
very positive no you can say foreigners
but he was a little bit like laca from
remember andy kaufman's latke it's sort
of like yes i think i like this
i must have just ripped it off watching
any coffee anyway i would call laser
hair removal places
and i would say yes i'd like uh some
hair to be removed uh oh yes okay and uh
where where is the place you were
concerned with
a on head and then my head
okay and did you want like the is it the
back of your neck or
no no top of head like a little hair
remove laser removed from side and then
leave at the top longer oh and then they
would eventually realize i was talking
about a haircut how old were you when
you wasted these innocent people's time
i was old enough to know better i'm
ashamed of it thank you for sorry i
really turned turned that into a light i
was just curious that was an innocent
question it was a teachable moment and i
haven't learned my lesson because you're
right i started my energy was more
braggy
and uh you're right i did i was too old
i was old enough to know but i was in
college but it's still funny you know it
was like calling moe's it was and now
maybe they have a story to tell too oh
okay maybe everybody wins okay that's a
nice way of looking so yeah see how i
did that oh wow you really uh a real
roller coaster this this episode so far
emotional roller coaster buckle up life
could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your kind of embarrassed host justin
long life could be a dream sweetheart
and with me as always is
christian my um
my
critical i thought are you gonna say
bashful
is there something
weird about calling referring to your
how would i say
embarrassing embarrassed bashful bashful
right yeah it's
maybe from the um uh snow white there's
no way seven doors i'm in little people
you can say seven dwarfs you can that's
the title okay
why are we talking about little people
well because we have a non-little person
on the show today that was a good time
but also we're talking about praying
phone calls and in terms of
cultural sensitivities uh uh which can
sometimes lead to canceling certain
things i said that in a very our guest
today has not been canceled nope um he
talks about cancer culture in a new book
and uh he was one of the co-creators of
the show cranky anchors so if you like
prank phone calls you'll know the show
and if
and or you should check it out our guest
today is adam carolla and i doubt he's
ever received such a shitty introduction
i don't think it was so shitty oh really
really round whatever but it was fun all
right uh he's just so good at this that
i momentarily got a little
self-conscious about how we're doing it
i think you're doing fine we do we do it
the way we do it that's true okay let's
not try to be anyone we're not i know
but he's been doing it for years and um
and he started i you all know his voice
he's been around for a long time we talk
about how he got a start in radio how he
uh came to relieve
well whatever now you were talking about
how the interview went yeah which is
really which is really no good no but
what we what we should say is
as far i believe we've only done a
hundred of these
plus yeah i believe that adam carol the
adam corolla show is
according to the guinness book of world
records is the most listened to podcast
of all time
that's the most listened to i believe
because it's a daily show and so it has
well you don't have to say wow you don't
qualify i'm not saying like we'd be in
contention for it
if not for our once a week would we be
in the top whoa top 500 i don't know if
we had an hourly show maybe
we just if we like did nothing but
podcasting he is uh really good at it
he's effortless at it so he's been doing
it for so long and that i'm not
qualifying and he's just a hell of a
talker he's a great talker and he's also
uh in addition to being the co-creator
of crank anchors which is an amazing
show he was also the co-creator and
co-host of the man show with jimmy
kimmel and love line oh right with dr
drew pinsky which i was honored to be a
future guest yes that'd be great i was
on that once and uh you reminded me that
you had tried to call in my you speaking
of prank phone calls you guys my friends
were all listening in a hotel room i
believe and that's right and you all one
by one tried to get through as like to
do a prank
and you were the only one that was
successful i was the only one to get
past the initial screening because you
have to when you call you have to talk
to a producer or something and and they
screen you were you nervous uh i might
have had a little liquid courage
thinking back on it this is a long time
ago this is like 15 years ago when you
were doing liquid acid yeah
uh and i got on and right away within
like
10 seconds of talking to to adam on the
show
he was like this i forget exactly what
he said but it was like something to be
effective this is [ __ ] i don't
believe you oh and i got nervous he
called me out he knew he knew he was a
prank yeah and he's really confident and
he'll go right in and that must have
been scary scary yeah but i was also
kind of proud that i got on
he yeah i'm sure we should try to dig
that up oh man you know i have it i have
it really yeah i have it down you said
that like jerry yeah yeah i have it
we've been seeing a lot of jerry
o'connell jerry was like the first
or at least one of the first people that
we saw out friends outside of quarantine
that's right that we hung out with uh we
got to see him in l.a shout out i hope
jerry's listening
i'm sure he is yeah we hung out with
jerry and asa two uh life is short
guests two friends of the show uh and
also two people that you know what it's
like what not a story hey let's get into
the show let's do it okay uh let's pull
a rip a page out of adam carolla's
playbook and you know if we keep doing
this we play our cards right we keep
having these great succinct funny
introductions maybe we'll be in the
guinness book of world's records fingers
crossed world's
uh anyway here it is
my
my chat i i've been on his show who
cares here it is it's adam carolla
right now it's adam cro who cares it's
adam carolla coming up on life is short
but what coming up on life is sure okay
as adam carolla how would you do it uh
up next my talk with the great adam
carolla okay that's better and
respectful
life
i can't believe it's been a year since i
saw you
god
i'm trying to think that was a year ago
in that studio
a great studio um
it was in the valley it's in the valley
yeah it's in glendale
and how far is that from where you grew
up adam
as the crow flies my studio is probably
four miles from where i grew up
oh wow and you're so you must know the
area
has it changed dramatically
um
yeah
i my i guess i would go yes and no would
be my answer a lot of old [ __ ] still
there but
and there's my studio
what's what's an old haunt that that's
still up that you remember and what's
one that's gone that you really miss
you know i didn't have a lot of old
haunts because i didn't have any money
you can have more humble homes yeah
there are a lot of places i used to pass
by but uh not a lot of places i used to
hang out in
you hadn't your family then was
they had no money they're still are they
still there hold on have we started yet
i don't know
yeah i think so okay
well then uh
yeah my family didn't have a lot of
money so we didn't really go to we
didn't have haunts we didn't really
have restaurants we would frequent
my family's kind of weird my dad
and mom didn't have like regular bars or
restaurants places
they didn't have hobbies or activities
they didn't really have friends jesus
it's kind of sad at home
well
they had no friends that's that that's
probably the most surprising one to me
well you know it's an interesting
yardstick to measure people because
when you say to someone
you have no friends they go what do you
mean i have a ton of friends
we should judge people and whether they
have friends
not by whether they think they have
friends
but by how people who live with them
observe them
and understand whether they have friends
or not you know what i mean because
everyone kind of thinks they have
friends like they like everyone thinks
they're a good person
but you shouldn't be able to decide
whether you're a good person your kids
your neighbors
that's the metrics
friends they should be able to decide
right and what do you think so have you
ever talked to any of their whoever they
whomever they would describe as their
friends have you ever talked to them
about your parents have you ever gleaned
any insight into your parents through
somebody like that
no because their friends were so sort of
few and far between it's not like we
were sitting at one of my haunts
with uh my parents friends and my
parents got up to go to the bathroom and
i could really chew on their ear for ten
minutes right right we we had um we had
a
we'd sometimes like to read would you
rather's and we had one the other day
that was would you rather
hear
uh everything everyone's ever said about
you
behind your back or
have everything you've said about
another person revealed to them
which would you rather yeah for me
i wouldn't want to hear everything that
everyone said about me behind my back
but i really wouldn't want
people to hear what i had to say about
them revealed to them oh yeah neither is
good yeah right but it's a lesser of two
evils but i will take
listening to what people had to say
about me because i feel like i would
rather be
crushed emotionally than crush someone
else emotionally
that's what we said yeah and and
although if it
if it was just you and i i would gladly
let you hear everything i had to say i
would take that option i would take that
option too i've i think only said good
things about you so i'd be safe
um i feel the same
uh your voice has been uh i almost said
comforting i guess it's comforting just
because it's been
around it's been my consciousness for so
long um
but i've been hearing you for for such a
long time are are people are you often
recognized you must be just be
recognized especially now with the mask
wearing just for your voice alone must
be so recognizable to people
yeah i i mean i was on the radio for so
long in los angeles uh and and
syndicated as well so yeah
i for a while that's kind of how people
knew me just from my voice because um
that's that's the way they consume me i
mean back before all the zoom and the
audio or video
and all that it was just a lot of love
line and morning radio and kevin and
bean and all that k rock and all that
kind of stuff so yeah i would get a lot
of that was radio an important
fixture in your life growing up in that
in that
life that you described was that it's
kind of a refuge for you
yeah
exactly it was i i always loved
conversations i always loved thoughts i
loved
hearing voices kind of like when you
turn the radio on before you leave the
house so your dog has a friend yeah i
kind of felt that way i was like the
lonely dog sitting at home and i just
needed voices to hear and then
i got out of i was always very social
and and conversational
and i got out of high school
which was
very social and conversational for me
and i got into construction
and i found myself just kind of working
as a laborer
on construction sites just digging
ditches and moving drywall and stuff
like that and it was really lonely
because i didn't really have anyone to
speak to and no one to speak to me
and it was in la so most of the laborers
were hispanic
and they they weren't getting my snl
references and they didn't know where
what the groundlings were and things
like that so i found myself
listening to a lot of talk radio like i
would just tune in to daytime talk radio
and just listen to
whomever was on oh that's interesting
well and it's also probably not a great
environment regardless of where they're
from just because you're
you're laboring you're doing physical
things there's probably a lot of noise
it's probably not the best um
environment to have a conversation or am
i or maybe maybe no i once
once in a while i mean it was a lot of
go over there and start digging and you
go over there and start digging and you
go over there and start loading into the
dumpster you know
pretty solitary stuff
i do remember very clearly every once in
a while there'd be some guy who wandered
on to the job site
who spoke good english and went to
college and was just there for like a
summer gig or
something like that or taking a semester
off of college and i i'd be like oh
here's a guy i can talk to
and one time me and one of those guys
were sitting up on some scaffolding
and we're doing a repointing job
repointing is when you take a
tuck trowel it's called it's a very
narrow trowel
and a hawk which is a thing with a
handle on it that's flat
on top like a pizza tray
and you put mortar on it you just tuck
it in between bricks on an old brick
building because the old mortar between
the bricks gets all
fatigued and you dig it out you tuck it
in and he and i were just sitting there
it's an endless task like you have to
picture like a massive brick wall and
you're just going to tuck new motors
in on each one wow and we're just
sitting there
talking sitting on the scaffoldings our
legs hanging down just tucking mortar in
and my foreman came by and he went hey
quit talking and he just walked by
so now we just sat there tucking mortar
endlessly
scared to talk
so that was kind of my life i'm
picturing like a laurel and hardy sure
quit talking yeah
like you're on a chain gang
yeah i know it kind of was like being on
a chain gang yeah
that's funny also like who cares if you
talk
uh well
that that was
uh
that was the point who cares if you talk
but
the
that world in those days
was a lot different than today's world
and that the the foreman was the foreman
he he needed you to do the task but he
also kind of it was kind of an army and
he was yeah you know i'm picturing like
cool and luke um
and i'm picturing you as somebody who
how did you respond to authority like
that you have such a subversive
uh
way about you i i or is that where that
was formed or did you not have that at
the time
i
w i was so desperate and needed a job so
badly that my plan was
um i'm just gonna eat it until i don't
have to eat it anymore i'll just take it
and so
i knew i was nobody i knew i desperately
needed a job i knew i could be replaced
by
any day labor waiting in the parking lot
of any home depot
he was happy not to talk
would have given you another a dollar an
hour discount if you didn't have to talk
uh
i knew i knew all that i was always very
realistic and maybe a little too
realistic so i was like i'll just suck
it up until i yeah until i don't have to
suck it up anymore well and did you have
at the time aspirations to do what was
the thing that you were working toward
was there a thing you were working
toward was it to be
on the radio one day
i always dreamt of being on the radio
but it was kind of a pipe dream i didn't
know anything about the radio i didn't
know anyone in radio it was it was a
mystery to me i you know
back then especially just turn you know
get my truck a turn on the radio not
hear these voices
but you know the thing is kind of
interesting is most radio studios don't
even have like signage out front or
anything they're kind of like
nondescript buildings well yours it's
kind of like that the one in glendale we
were talking about it you wouldn't
really know it was a studio uh
from the outside
no you wouldn't and
you know it doesn't really matter i
guess these days but uh
back then
there were a couple of places where like
halo s was that way like you knew where
they were but most radio stations i had
no idea so i didn't know where they were
i didn't know who th i didn't know what
the people looked like who were talking
you know like you couldn't just go find
pictures of people on the internet
that's true and it was it was it was an
enigma to me and i had no ins i knew
nobody so my take was well
i i guess i'll just dream on about it
so then snl you mentioned uh in an
attempt to speak with the other people
was snl something that you you loved but
did you
was
was that the same thing was it like oh
that's just an abstract thing that i
enjoy watching but it's not like a real
there's there's no way i can actually be
on that
yeah all all
professional forms of entertainment for
me was just some abstract thing you know
being a comedian on a cruise ship or
any of that stuff was all just
i have no idea what any of this is who
you know how you get there
i you know you get an agent you get a
photographer you get head shots like
i i knew nothing and i had you know
little to no expectations of ever
cracking into that world
and so what was the thing this is
probably too big a question to answer
quickly but but what was the thing that
allowed you to do that was there or was
there a single thing
there there really wasn't a single thing
i was just
very philosophical about it i just
thought um
well
i know i know what i have now what i
have now is just me on a construction
site making nine bucks an hour
with a bunch of guys that i don't really
that aren't that funny and don't want to
talk
and a mean foreman so that much i know i
i know what i have
um i don't have any outside means of
support or money or any anybody who owns
a used car dealership they could get me
a job on or owns a restaurant or they'd
let me bartend or or something i i had
no connections
and where were your parents at this
point adam what were you close with them
at the time
um we've never really been that close my
mom had never really worked she was kind
of um welfare food stamps and then just
became a
full-time student for
a million years at like la valley
college
my dad was um
a director of education he was basically
a school teacher
essentially
at an orphanage as they used to call
them uh in altadena and then he
did that for 10 years and then he wanted
to get his psychological his his degree
in psychology so he was kind of a
student my mom didn't work
they both had remarried my stepdad
worked at lockheed
um and my stepmom worked like as an
administrator like an office person at
ucla so i didn't i didn't know i didn't
have any places i could go or any family
business or anything right
and they were you know pretty
tight-fisted with the money the help or
the whatever and then really have
anything
so
they're both kind of married to people
that made money but those people
weren't going to say to me you know take
a year off and find right off or learn
learn
the the uh art of comedy or anything
so i i kind of knew i was just kind of
alone
so i just started
i signed up for a groundlings class and
i was like 22 or something and i was
like i'll just
i'll just plot along i have no
expectations i'll see
how i am
and you worked your way up in the
because i know that we took groundlings
come up comes up a lot on the show uh
it's obviously a place where a lot of
people got their start um but i also
know that it's very competitive um is it
was it something that you you were
thriving in that world or
did that just lead to the next thing
um
it was determined basically that i was
funny
but that was about it we didn't really
know
if i could act or or do anything else as
it pertained to you know improvisational
comedy or sketch comedy were you doing
characters
no i was i
little bits and pieces i i was never
really any good at characters so it was
just all we
had was oh this guy's funny that that
was about it
uh-huh and did they
try to was there somebody that you were
compared to or molding yourself after
like i'm thinking about like kevin
nealon or somebody that you maybe
aspired to be like like that whose
comedic niche you might help fill
then you know that was kind of a that
would have been a little lofty for me at
that point like you would be the next
you know fill in the blank
i didn't uh i didn't have any
aspirations of that i
they just told me at the groundlings
you're funny you can't act go take an
acting class and then after you take
your acting class you can come back and
you can take intermediate or something
like that oh no kidding so did you do
that
yeah
uh
uh huh
and then you return to the groundlings
with it did you feel more comfortable as
an actor after the class
no not i mean not per se all i did was
figure out they were right i was a bad
actor
trying to act in an acting class and i
felt like i stunk
and so it was just kind of confirmed and
certified that i couldn't act at the
acting class it didn't really teach me
how to act per se i'm sure i got
something out of it
but but you're a natural performer see
that surprises me because you're
somebody who seems very comfortable
um
doing comedy and that to me is it's all
performance based i
i and i've seen you in things i've seen
you be very comfortable and natural
certainly even on the man show even
hosting something
isn't there an enough of an element of
acting that
i'm surprised that didn't translate into
sketch acting
yeah i don't i mean i guess i was okay i
didn't really have my feet under me at
that point i had no any kind of formal
anything i was kind of a jock in high
school and then i just went on to
construction sites so i really didn't
i didn't have a base um yeah but i
thought that
there was something there i thought i
was funny
so i thought well maybe i can
maybe i can work on it you know maybe i
can see if i can find find a way to
harness it or direct it
and did you meet jimmy kimmel through
the groundlings did you meet him now in
that world no i i didn't meet jimmy
uh
i didn't meet jimmy for years after i
got started growling i probably ate nine
years probably i didn't mean until eight
or nine years later
and so what was that time like are you
still doing odd jobs are you still doing
construction during that time
oh yeah that's all i got i mean i'm i'm
you know living on my own you know i
have an apartment i have roommates i got
a truck you know i got bills and i got
to eat and
i work full-time construction
my entire my entire life
wow is that see sometimes i romanticize
somebody who is incapable of that kind
of work uh i i still romanticize it was
there ever do you ever miss it in that
sense do you ever miss the kind of
i don't know the freedom and you're
outside and you're working with your
hands yeah and i've done a lot of it in
my homes over the years and lots of
various projects and things like that
i like having a knowledge base i like
understanding all that i understood i i
worked
in a lot of different facets of the
business i worked in cabinet shops i
worked making custom closets and like a
european style
cabinet shop i work earthquake rehab i
did tons of residential remods and some
commercial work and that ti they call it
tenant improvement stuff so
i got exposed to
all facets of building and construction
and so
now i know how it works or i've always
known how it works so it's it's good to
know it's i built this studio and it was
good to know how to how to build stuff
when you build this cool so if you
wanted to build like a little guest
house where you live could you do
something like that i can build whatever
i want wow but that's cool uh yeah i i
guess it's cool i you know it it's not
really practical for me to
do that now
in terms of the use use of time but i do
a lot of projects and i supervise them
and i understand everything that's
happening
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
when did you meet jimmy and how
drastically did that change things for
you
in the entertainment world
well the story goes
that um
and it changes very dramatically for me
very quickly
um the story goes that
i i was also toward the end of of my
carpentry career i was also a boxing
coach
so
i i worked at a place called um
bodies in motion and i was working in uh
old town pasadena
and i was just i would teach a morning
class like an early morning class like a
6 30 class and then i would
go
do my carpentry and in heaven and by
then
i wasn't working for an outfit or a
company at a certain point
i don't know maybe the last couple two
three years of my carpentry career i
just kind of broke off and i did my own
jobs and
so
the word you know like jesus hmm like
jesus jesus yes yeah except for
i didn't gouge the elderly
or go crazy in a temple that's right i
um you get it you work for enough people
you do good work you're reasonable
you know you don't steal the
prescription medication they trust you
in their house and they just want you to
come back and do more stuff and then
they start you know then their friends
start going do you got a guy and then
they go oh yeah this guy at him he's
really good he's trustworthy wow you
were the guy for a bunch of people then
that's cool yeah i worked for like katie
seagal
oh no kidding yeah i worked for i got on
a little there's a weird thing so
there's a little bit of a celebrity
assistant
circuit
which is the assistants
kind of all talk to each other
oh god speaking of what we were talking
about earlier would you want to hear how
people really felt about you well as it
pertained to carpentry and carpentry
alone i would be fine because i was
cheap i was prompt i was sober and i did
good work you know so they were all i
was quiet when i was in their house so
they would recommend me like
this assistant would say oh i got a guy
and next thing you know i'd be over at
their house building them an
entertainment unit or something oh huh
so
did katie seagal lead to other celebrity
jobs and stuff uh yeah there are a
couple of people not like a-listers i
have some vague recollection for some
reason of like scott baio's assistant
wanting me to do some work i can't
remember if i did it or not but um
i just worked independently for the last
few years so i would work
as a boxing coach during the day
and then it in in the morning afternoon
whatever i would i would do my job i
would do
as a carpenter and how did the boxing
stuff come up is that something you did
in high school
were you a proficient boxer yourself
i was proficient
but
i was never a great boxer but i i i knew
how to box and i i knew how to teach it
kind of more importantly
and
so i was a good instructor but
the boss of the gym he didn't really
like me or the way i instructed because
he was kind of treating it like a
fitness camp for secretaries and i was
more like i got to teach
the uh
the sweet science of boxing yeah
the art
the art of boxing so i was doing a lot
of that
so eventually the only people that took
my class were just dudes in their 40s
who wanted to really learn how to box
versus all the hot chicks who just
wanted to burn calories well that's a
shame
it is when you're single yeah yeah yeah
uh so then you i do you know misty
friedman by the way misty's my old
boxing trainer she worked at justin
you would know him
squat tough he has a place on sunset
he's boxing sunset what's this called do
you remember
uh fortune
fortune
i never went in there i don't think i'm
trying to think of a place on sunset
uh now since moved to beverly yeah
whatever um
whatever do you uh what happens you're
an expert at this you're a podcasting
radio expert what happens when something
like what just happened happens well
it just falls dead you don't know the
person i have a reference it's not going
to be interesting for anyone else to
hear
what would you do in that situation
where do you take it
you know
you try to avoid those situations in
general
but when they do arise and inevitably
they're going to
you then try to figure out like your
plan b like what other
what else did we hear in this
conversation
and make something of but then also
it is part i think it's why people like
these conversations because they feel
like organic and that organically if you
and i
went out to lunch and we're speaking
that would happen five times that's true
that's true
that's true we we had another would you
rather you might be able to help us out
with um
somebody said well we were talking about
farting we were talking about farting
and and when it could be the most
embarrassing and how you react to
somebody when they do it
and somebody there was a
hypothetical scenario where you're on a
date
with someone and they fart
uh really loudly and obviously they're
embarrassed right away
how do you
how do you
alleviate some of the embarrassment for
them what's what would be your move
so they fart very loudly on a date and
they're
and they put their head in their hands
and they're
it's very they know you know
yes it's obvious okay
so there's a couple things
you say on the date but
where on the date or you're at a
restaurant you're driving you're in a
restaurant
yeah you're let's say you're at the
restaurant if you're at the restaurant
you have to make a food joke
right
so
you have to go
next time we won't do cuban
you know that's it yes yes blame it on
something else yeah you blame it you
blame it on something else
if you have a the best thing you could
do for that individual
is if you have a fart chambered to let
it fly oh that moment oh that's like a
saint you'd be a saint yeah
yeah yeah that someone should get
canonized for doing that that's
basically
the version of you're on a date and the
person goes i
i'm i think of you in a kind of serious
manner and i know this is going
somewhere
i think i should tell you i have herpes
that's right up there if you're going oh
i have herpes too
yes yes that's about the best thing you
could do that's a real limits test for
how how much you like somebody i will
sometimes fart and shout have herpes at
the same time
just unsolicited
yeah uh hopefully it's based on them
farting but not necessarily
uh just so they in the future will feel
more comfortable to review both of those
things get this out of the way
um
you so okay i'm i shouldn't labor the
point about jimmy but i feel like that
was a huge moment in your yeah well he
was he was
working at k rock radio
as jimmy the sports guy
there was some sort of boxing match that
they were talking about on the air
kind of a morning zoo thing
yeah and uh they needed and so the call
went out you know we need instructors we
need people who can teach we need a
venue we need equipment you know they
just kind of
put it out into the into the airwaves
and i was listening and i was like oh
i'm going to teach
i want to teach one of these guys to box
it wasn't necessarily jimmy it could
have been the guy he was boxing it
didn't really matter yeah actually i
kind of wanted to teach the guy
michael the maintenance man the guy he
was going to be boxing because michael
the maintenance man had been there for
like three years maybe four years and
jimmy had only been there a few months
huh
um
so you volunteered for so you became
then oh connection is unstable
but as it's as it turns out you ended up
being okay but you ended up teaching
jimmy um
and did do you just hit it off right
away
yeah
i teach jimmy we hit it off right away
i try to convince him i'm i'm funny
i do convince him i'm funny
and uh now
you know we have two or three weeks
before the fight
and i'm just trying to convince him i'm
funny and to help me
and to see like
you're supposed to be
training me you're supposed to be
helping me box uh
do you
do you ever remember him being like all
right i get it but you know let's let's
get back to boxing
he didn't want a box i mean he didn't
want to train he wanted to hang out and
talk to me
and i wanted to hang out and talk to him
so oh that's you know we had the roller
skate in the key
and i and i i was very mindful and
careful not to just come across like
some desperate budding comedian who was
not him out for his help like
i wanted to i was a legitimate boxing
coach and so i did i did start that
slowly
so then what's the first thing who who
broaches the let's move this from
let's let's uh graduate to like either
friends or we work together
how does that happen
um the fight was coming up in a few
weeks
i kind of knew i had that time to kind
of slowly start introducing
to jimmy my goals or my aspiration or
whatever
and i i started doing that and he
started to understand that i was a funny
person and and i think he really
understood it at a certain point and
then then the fight came and went and
jimmy lost the fight
and uh you know then it just became a
kind of uh well well what's next the
fight's over
you think i'm funny
but what can we do
and jimmy didn't have a lot of juice or
sway at the station he wasn't the
morning show guy he was a part of the
morning show crew you know
so he wasn't really going to be able to
tell the program director or kevin or
being like hey here's what i need you to
do for me yeah he was gonna be able to i
had a voice on the inside
in jimmy but he really wasn't gonna
dictate anything to anybody
so
he said
what do you do like what what do you
think you would do what would you do on
this morning show
um and i said uh i'd hang around and i
would crack wise and i would be funny i
would help you know yeah and he he said
you can't do that kevin bean that's what
kevin and bean do to hang out and crack
wise why do you need to hang out and
crack wise with them
and i said well i that's kind of what i
do that's all i got you know and he said
well if you want to get on the air you
got to come up with a character
and i said oh i don't really do
characters and he said well
you better figure it out
and uh that was about it so he said
figure it out
i think he told me that he told them
this guy's gonna be calling in monday
morning at 7 30 just you know
go with it like i'm not he didn't tell
him it was the boxing coach because he
didn't want him to think that the boxing
coach wanted
one to be a comedian so he just kind of
said i i got this guy he's funny i guess
he's going to do a character just let
him call in monday morning
and then he kind of said to me it's
probably not going to go anywhere like
kevin and bean are kind of finicky and
you know they might probably not
he didn't say they're not going to like
it he just kind of said
be prepared manage your expectations
this may be a kind of one-and-done
situation
and i called in monday morning you know
very nervous and i did this character
and
and it went well
sorry adam what was the character
what was it
character was uh named mr burcham the
woodshop teacher and he taught
uh
at louis pasteur middle school in
monrovia and he taught
um remedial wood
i i made this class up but
he was a wood shop teacher because i
knew carpentry real well so i was like
i'll do a character where i understand
the i understand the topic of the
character the subject matter
and it was good it went it went well
and uh you know i called jimmy afterward
or like what'd they think like how'd it
go and and i i kind of recall him going
yeah they they liked it they liked it
like so
call in next week you could call in next
week and do it again
and i i did
for several weeks and and then the
character became a sensation it became a
huge wow and
next thing you know
mr burcham was like a big hit
on k rock
and it was it was weird because then my
character became bigger than jimmy's
character jimmy the sports guy
his boxing coach got on the air and ten
minutes later he's the big star of the
morning show and as mr burcham you say
you don't do characters but was he
basically
how similar was he to you how much of a
character was it and and then does it
become like well that's just kind of you
so you're becoming big
well i'd always kind of joked about how
awful my shop teachers were in junior
high and how mean they were and how
gruff they were and
the wood shop teacher and the metal shop
teacher and stuff and
every time i had that conversation with
somebody like oh my [ __ ] my shop teacher
you know mr cage oh he was the worst you
know he'd throw people's projects away
and he'd paddle people and he screamed
you know he was like really hostile yeah
like like there was a
it seemed to be kind of a universal
thing
that people had these horrible shop
teachers that were really mean and so i
thought maybe i struck a nerve here so
i just developed this guy
who was the you know he he loved
woodworking but he hated kids
and so like
he was in a shop all day filled with
tools and woodworking and stuff but he
hated the fact that there were kids and
what he considered his shop
like that
yeah but they were yeah yeah
it's like it's like when you get that
really mean person working security at
lax like their mentality is is hey if
you were never born i could relax and
it's like right right right
no you're not making it wrong yeah yeah
right you shouldn't be here you're
making this really hard for me i could
just be doing nothing right yeah that's
funny that's really funny idea and and
were you doing things i mean i imagine
you know we're
we have to talk about um
your book and and the
stuff you talk about in the book a lot
of a lot of it has to do with uh you've
been talking about cancer culture i'm
thinking about stuff that you must have
done back then
how
dicey it must be now i mean some of that
that a character like that i imagine you
have
kind of carp launched to
say whatever because it's it's through
the voice of this really like unlikable
hostile
guy
yeah he was pretty much like an archie
bunker type character right and he would
say all these horrible things like
during open house you know he'd he
he would use the
see that the rub or the gimmick was that
he would use
kevin and bean
and the radio and their young
demographic audience to speak to his
kids through the radio because he would
call in
[Music]
so he would he it was pretty well
thought out character which is
because the first question is a
groundlings alum you know i was like why
does this guy call kevin and bean what
right what would be his motivation
for calling kevin and bean
and what i came up with is
i would call like 7 15 in the morning
and the conceit was
i don't like kevin and bean i don't like
k rock i don't like any of that
crappy music like i would go i don't
like all your you know
nervosa and smashing dumplings and that
crap music
you play
but
my kids all have it tuned in back when
people had clock radios right like it's
all
k rock so i want to talk to mike oh
that's funny and that's i would use
kevin to be like an intercom
speak to the kids yeah and i would say
these horrible things like
i remember you you just reminded me i
haven't thought about it a million years
but
talking about things you couldn't really
say anymore i would like it's like it
would be like open house tonight
and i'm gonna speak to uh tim the kid
with the lesbian parents you know what i
mean you gotta tell them in advance you
gotta decide which one's papa it's too
goddamn confusion to me have you coming
in and
if you're gonna dip you bring enough
skull for both of us
and
horrible things like that
to them all the time but it was like
archie bunker again like yeah yeah yeah
that's the beauty of a character like
that and of archie bunker and um
that you can
you know it also reveals people's
how funny like
people's bigotry can be
uh and and
but but it's really making fun of the
guy i mean that's the thing about and we
should talk about
um the book and cancel culture i feel
like that's a good way in just because
um
i think it's a shame to not be able to
do that you're
losing out on a lot of great satire and
and um
losing out on on calling out effectively
calling out some of these people like
archie bunker types um
well
part the sad part about archie bunker
are all in the family is
my i used to watch that show growing up
i'd watch it with my mom who is
one of the most liberal people on the
planet
and
when i was eight
i understood that archie bunker was
he was
the antagonist
right he was
it's it's almost like saying
it's kind of like saying
well how could we have james bond when
bond villains are evil it's like well
that's the way it works we know that
guy's a bad guy and that james bond is a
good guy and now he's gonna defeat the
bad guy
and it was like archie bunker
was the guy and my mom would laugh
at archie bunker like she she everyone
understood it that's who he was and then
at the end
he'd get bested every time by meet head
or sammy davis jr or whoever get his
comeuppance right and that was and
that's what it is and my super liberal
mom liked it that way and understood it
yeah
so i don't i don't get where we've slid
to where we're not allowed to have this
character
i don't know how it happened i'm sure
there were a lot of things that
contributed to it but i think a better i
think a more recent rather example of it
is michael scott on the office and i
know that
there was one funny i was talking to my
friend who has um
whose kid is very woke uh very
into what culture and
and is very sensitive to that kind of
stuff and and was saying to my friend
who's an actor a really good actor my
friend was lamenting the fact that he
can't tell these stories the way he used
to you know he can't um he's like you
know she gets
she's 12. she gets pissed at me every
time i do a voice of a mexican person or
a chinese bra i can't do characters
anymore when i'm telling these stories
she gets really upset
and then she found out that her the
office is her favorite show the american
office and she found out that there's an
episode that they don't show on netflix
anymore and she said well
why not and he said well it's the one
where
michael scott is is in blackface he he
wears black and she says yeah but
he's the one that looks like an idiot
it's he ends up he's the buffoonish one
and it reveals his own
uh you know idiocy and that's that she's
12 and she got that
um so i and like you said
when you were when you were a kid you're
watching all in the family
it strikes me as something that's
so
uh easily understood i don't
i don't know why that can't be explained
in culture anymore i know i don't know
why that can't be just how
we can't justify it anymore
you know we we started down this road
where
we started to buy into this belief which
is
well we know it's a joke but there are
other people watching that are going to
be empowered by it
right well the
or somehow be motivated by it
you know it's funny you say that because
i remember my dad telling me that his
dad
would laugh with archie bunk he didn't
quite get the conceit he didn't really
understand the satire
he was one of those people but then he
people like that i feel like they
will won't they just is this wishful
thinking won't they and that mentality
just die off i mean or is it isn't it so
limited to maybe not i mean maybe that's
what we're finding out now that it's
it's not limited to it just a
very small group of people it's uh
more pervasive well
but you know here's the thing
basically the group that is trying to
get rid of archie bunker is essentially
the same group that was arguing that
lyrics and
rock songs and violent video games
didn't really affect anybody
right the two life crew right so it yeah
what i'm basically saying is is
you can't have it both ways you can't
say violent video games don't make
people violent but archie bunker is a
call to action for white supremacists
the the the bottom line is
you can't control everything
yeah at some point you're going to have
to step back and realize that
people ingest information in different
ways and you just can't
trying to control everything
actually ends up with a worse outcome
than a percentage of people
getting the wrong message from whomever
it is you disagree with
well what is that then adam what is what
what
enabled those people to have such a
powerful voice the um
the ones that
are easily offended um it was it twitter
is it as simple as social media has has
amplified those
voices to the point where they're now
influencing culture
you know i mean twitter and and all that
big tech stuff is something that we just
haven't evolved
fast enough into
right so
you know we're not made
to go from driving a horse and a buggy
to driving a ferrari in 10 minutes that
that kind of stuff takes 75 years you
know what i mean
and
because of the digital age it just
happened in 10 minutes
right so we're not acclimated you know
and when you're not acclimated
so you know if you think about something
you take the horse and buggy and you
take automobiles you know
i've never really thought about it but
we'll see if we can parse this out
everyone rode a horse wrote a buggy a
wagon or whatever and then at some point
you know they came out with the model t
and people drove that around and they
started going well i think we need paved
roads if people are gonna do this like
so they started like paving some roads
but half the people were still riding a
horse and the other half were riding
them driving a model t
and then at some point they went i guess
we should have stoplights if we're going
to have people
and then you're right it was a gradual
election 25 years after that they were
like
i think we need police because some
people are going too fast you know
now it's giving way to rolling through a
four-way stop sign at 2 a.m burbank but
but either way
we had a hundred years to kind of slow
that's true implement stuff and the
thing about the internet
and twitter
and all that it was like we're all
riding horses and now we're all riding
shotgun in a ferrari and it's like true
what the [ __ ] is going on and so
uh and and
realistically everyone has a different
idea now like here's how we need to
police this here's how we need to work
it because
it came on so fast it was right in our
laps of course everyone's going to have
a different idea
it would have done the same with cars if
we just went you know in in nine months
we're all just driving ferrari we'd be
arguing over stop lights and parking
tickets of course nothing would make
sense you know and yeah a thousand
different directions we'd be going what
what bumper stickers are mandatory right
yeah what so what is the price what
would your prescription be i mean how do
we get this under control because um
i know you're someone who's gotten in
quote unquote gotten in trouble a lot
and
and you seem to have weathered it i mean
you're
still able to say what you want to say
or are you not i mean do you feel
constricted at all by the rules and the
let's call it like woke police
no i think everyone who speaks into a
microphone
understands that the woke police are out
there
but and you know
i don't think
it's uh
you know for some people it affects them
85 percent and for some people it
affects them five percent you know i
don't know that there's a zero
effect per se
um i'm just on the much lower scale you
know i'm just three percent for me um
two things
so one is
my feeling is is why did why did i get
into comedy
and why did i want to speak into a
microphone and i realized if i start
thinking about what people want to hear
versus what i want to say or how it's
going to be perceived or construed then
i'm in the wrong business like i
you should not i should go back to being
a carpenter if i'm going to start put
putting a governor on myself and trying
to figure out
how people are going to react to what i
have to say
or modifying what i want to say and in
my thoughts so it's but philosophical
thing for me but but isn't that the
function of some people that you do the
show with i remember doing your show
when we were whenever that was a year
ago and
you had people on the show that had
different points of view yes and you had
voices that were
certainly not policing you but offering
different
perspectives yes is that important to
you is it important to have
um
that kind of set up for a
for a richer conversation i think so
yeah i don't want to live in an echo
chamber
brian and gina who are on my show have
very different views than me on many
different subjects and they voice those
views and sometimes we argue or
sometimes we debate and sometimes
uh you know they give their opinion i
give my opinion and it's probably
a more practical
way to to convey that i don't i don't
know that a lot of people do that
anymore right or left it seems to me
that everyone's just kind of in their
chamber
and when you do get i mean do you notice
when you cause a little bit of an uproar
do you do you are you active on twitter
how do you how does that stuff find you
how does that offen the
offended parties how do they reach out
to you uh i will see stuff on twitter
sometimes there'll be some articles or
something people forward stuff i don't i
don't really seek it out
per se
but uh some people will make me aware of
it producer my podcast something like
that
and um you know i just get that's the
world we're living in you know it's
there's a there's a context to it you
know yeah and also
i'm secure in me as a as a human being i
i know i'm a good person i know i i take
care of people and i know
that
whatever they're trying to call me
you know like let's just say
i'm accused of being a racist
well i don't have a racist bone in my
body so it doesn't
it it doesn't offend you it doesn't
really
the seed doesn't
find a purchase
with me it's like it's like if you said
to me
i know adam molest his kids
i would just laugh because like i joke
but because you but because you know
that that's so untrue and i imagine
other people hearing that people in your
life
might take it more seriously than you do
don't you have an instinct to then want
to defend yourself and explain that
you're not
well i mean sometimes
i'll read a tweet and it'll say you know
adam only looks out for adam he doesn't
like working people he thinks he's he
thinks he's a he's an elitist he wants
to i wrote that before i knew of your
background i'm sorry and then i'd wrote
back like i will tell that to the 20
people have never missed a paycheck who
work with me all through this covet
situation and uh you know he doesn't
like working class guys and i'll just
tweet back all right i'll fire all the
working-class guys i've employed for all
these years tomorrow yeah yeah yeah i'll
defend myself
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry adam i know we're running out
of time i gotta pivot quickly to our uh
to our lightning round we have a quick
fun lightning round even though i love
talking about this with you um
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say
oh i don't use emojis i'm not never not
good enough
you never use them never you don't i
will i will emoji someone who emojied me
sometimes just to make them feel like i
got your emoji back i don't want you to
live on emoji island without
something you don't want that floating a
smiley face will come up and i'll hit it
on rare occasion but i also know that
people know it's me and they know i must
think it's [ __ ]
it'll come across as wildly insincere uh
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play you said you
were a jock in high school what sports
did you play i played football and
baseball i always loved football and so
it would always be football
were you a tight end why am i i think
that no i was a uh linebacker and an
offensive lineman
oh whoa wow positions
and your team now is uh were you a rams
fan or a raiders fan i was a rams fan
just because i grew up you know i've
grown up in l.a i've been here my whole
life so
i like football so i like the poor rams
well there were some great years then
they've had a few good jack kemp and
derek dickerson was my favorite
um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be well
i'll say what popped in my head although
i realized not a snack food sees candy i
love that box that sees candy but really
uh yeah snack food
would be i see seas counts i think if
you're all right in fact
yeah but but but now i'm curious snap
food if you just want to like munch on
something you're a little stoned you're
watching tv uh i would say
like
smoked almonds
oh yeah nice oh great um what is your
favorite movie sequel of all time
which die hard were you in
the fourth one that's
great answer that's the one or
jaws two oh
come on but was that the one where he
bites the electrical line i think yeah i
think so um
yeah i'm i'm trying to i'm trying to
think legitimately
you know obviously godfather but that's
kind of yeah that's that's a little too
easy
um let's go karate kid too mix it up the
one where he goes to japan yeah
okay
god have you been watching that show i
just i just talked to him on this show
ralph uh machio that was a
thrill he's a nice guy
what a nice guy yeah an unbelievably
youthful looking star unbelievably
youthful but if you stood
on a pier pylon and did
your kata every day for two hours i feel
like you look brand new as well and i
feel about
myself yeah you
how old are you you do look good i'm 56.
oh wow close to ralph yeah okay
similarly
well preserved uh what is your go-to do
you go sing karaoke ever is that a thing
that you do uh it's been tough during
the pandemic
well right but uh when i do
my go-to song would be a vehicle by the
ides of march
so anyone listening can just go google
that and i think you'll you'll you'll
get it i understand why okay um and your
first celebrity crush growing up in the
valley in la
uh who did you have a crush on i'm gonna
go
with dom deluise
i know
i'm gonna go
with cheryl ladd
because i watched charlie's angels when
i was a kid i thought she was just the
best
oh yeah yeah jordan ladd was a friend
still is a friend of mine and it's
remarkable how similar they looked um
yeah although dom deluise would have
been a fine
choice you're not judging
i'm not laughing at it
um
if you had to get a tattoo do you have
any tattoos no
if you you don't want one
um
no but you know at this point i don't
think it's gonna be a game changer for
me right right
well if you had to get one what would it
be and where would you get it
um
jimmy kimmel once
told me and this is uh going to be in
vain with our charlie's angels 70s tv
you know uh must watch friday night
schedule
he told me if he ever got a tattoo it
would be of tattoo from fantasy island
oh that's great i'm gonna go along with
that tattoo
that's great
um
are you still close with jimmy yeah
yeah uh that's good
um
i just know you guys so well together i
listen to love line so much um did you
miss doing love line giving relationship
advice
yeah i missed that job i miss hanging
out with dr drew every night it was an
easy job for me and
it was really fun it was in the middle
of the night like it was my thing i
really enjoyed that job
that something be something that you
could do today in today's climate uh
based on what we were talking about do
you think you'd still be able to do that
well it's kind of weird because people
do say could you do x y and z in today's
climate but kind of getting back to what
we alluded to
i do feel like i could do it i don't
know if other people could do it i mean
maybe you've been grandfathered in well
i i shouldn't say i could do it i would
say i would do it i would i would say
what i had to say you have a book coming
out uh the books i am your emotional
support animal navigating our woke no
joke culture
okay now i gotta read this now because
it's it's something i'm so fascinated by
and i i'm
often have a hard time navigating it
there's so many things that come up on
this show we think oh
god every couple of minutes
something makes me laugh and i
immediately think oh you can't do it
anymore right my remedy for that is if
everyone just started doing it at the
same time on monday
uh it would go away we could do it right
though we just need to do it right
and i did it in that book that book is
uh has plenty of that in it but but but
a lot of comedy it's first and foremost
a comedy book
oh i can't wait to read it do you read
the audio version too yeah is there an
audio yes there's an audio version of it
and i i read it all with some sidebar
you know improv as well
oh cool okay that's the one i'll get um
uh what is your favorite fruit
nectarine
nah okay
huh
you had that already i i had a feeling
you're gonna ask i wrote it there oh
really
i like uh i will also say only it's kind
of seasonal but the rainier cherry the
cherries that are kind of yellow and red
gotcha it's kind of orange
oranges yeah meaty rainier are those
meaty
are there seed not seedless are these
kids in them but they're still so good
okay oh man sounds good uh who would you
want to play you in a biopic in your in
the adam corolla
biopic
um idris elba
washington uh tiffany haddish
on the top of my head dom de la os he's
dead
um you know everyone always just says uh
oh you're like gilbert godfrey so i
guess we'd have gilbert godfrey do it
oh yeah you do have a similar i mean
yeah how do you feel about that
comparison uh i'd rather have the
george clooney or patrick dempsey
comparison but uh you know you don't get
to sign those people are signed right
you're not offended oh actually uh i
know because uh jimmy used to say
you look like pete sampras if pete
sampras had down syndrome
it seems cruel
but somehow yes struck a nerve
you do look like pete sampras
if pete sampras had down syndrome right
right who's your favorite simpsons
character or were you a muppets guy
growing up adam did you like the muppets
no
um but i will go
with um
oh uh troy mcclure
oh yeah the great philharmonic
philharmonic troy mcclure always cracked
me up like every time there was a
commercial
for uh troy mcclure in his movies or
infomercials or whatever it was always
the best i i loved yeah
yeah um dogs are cats
i love them both but i'll just say cat
to be a little counter culture i love
cats
okay although yeah we've had a lot of do
you have pets yourself
yeah i have a uh labrador that's um
120 pounds and sleeps on top of my son
every night i love him i love him hot
dog yeah uh well he's gonna love that
you just said cats um beetles are the
rolling stones
uh
that's close i i i like the beatles i do
think the rolling stones rock a little
harder with certain songs like [ __ ] you
know which i love but uh and i'd also
probably say the who who i think rock a
little hard than the rolling stones and
the beatles but yeah day in day out you
got to go with the beatles
yeah and if you're at a bar and uh you
go to the jukebox you want to put in a
couple beatles songs what are the first
that come to mind that you would type in
um
i'd have to go
with a day in the life
oh god and um
long and windy road i think oh yeah
beautiful yes day in the life was like
so many different songs in one
it's such a varied um
and it's friends is on and seinfeld's on
which one do you watch
um
i think friends even though seinfeld's
maybe better or funnier i think there's
some sort of comfort food like with
friends yeah for me like
and speaking of comfort food you're at a
barbecue
you just want a burger what do you put
on it i would put
cheese pickle tomato raw onion hopefully
a little spread and uh wow that'll
probably probably do it well
that'll probably do this thanks buddy i
i i could talk to you so much longer and
as fate would have it we're going to
fortunately yeah we'll do it on uh on uh
take any my inspirational motivational
podcast that's on any platform any of
the podcast platforms i think you can go
to adamcorolla.com and find it's
probably at apple and all those places
too but uh talk to people from all walks
of life uh and people know the adam
corolla show that's still on as well uh
doing very yeah you can get biggest on
amazon too and you can find out where
i'm doing live dates i do stand up
around the country so you can just go to
adamkarola.com adamcorolla.com and the
book is i'm your emotional support
animal navigating are all woke no joke
culture
um well i this i love talking to you uh
you've been somebody i've so enjoyed
hearing the last two decades so uh this
was a treat thanks buddy appreciate you
doing it
thanks justin
so that happened so that happened so
that happened so that ah kind of like
how's that
it's a little bit it's a little
insulting
yeah yeah no he's got a cooler voice
than that but it's a little there's
something
yeah you know you sound a little bit
like louis anderson
a little bit you know you sound like a
combination of louis anderson and
sam ishmael oh wow
three of you may get that reference emmy
rossum's husband
what do you think the odds are that
creator of mr robot i know who he is i
know but he's he's a person that people
know yeah but he's not i wouldn't say
he's like a personality he's not he's on
a voice that people are super familiar
with well for those of us that sounded
like him for the few of you who aren't
this is kind of how he sounds yeah
what'd you think
uh i was happy that he
called himself out for sounding like
gilbert godfrey because i was thinking
it the entire time yes that's who it is
yes i never realize how much he does
sound like him yeah
a little bit more nor like normal or
like not quiet because gilbert
gilbert doesn't he plays it up what does
that remind you of gilbert gilbert
gilbert
hmm
um gilbert and solomon uh
anyway um
but but he he definitely plays it up you
tried to balance off that reference with
the classy wrestlers yeah i guess i did
you know i think i could feel myself
going through that thought process i
actually
because i was like i should now
reference another
you caught me yeah i did
bust um pretentious bust
uh yeah gilbert he does sound like
gilbert gottfried but what were you
gonna say about him well that when he's
not doing his shtick
when he's just kind of talking it's
almost disarming how
les gilbert godfrey yeah he sounds and
in fact sounds just like ham corolla
and he looks a bit like him uh-huh
yep they could be related totally yeah
what a great sibling casting that would
be
yeah we should write a movie about the
two
for the two of them yeah the only
problem with gilbert godfrey playing the
lead in a movie i i feel i really like
gilbert godfrey i don't i fear and he
would probably agree with this i would
guess it might be a little grating not
if he didn't play up the voice exactly
what if can't you see this can you see
gilbert godfrey being cast by like uh
alexander
yeah yeah yeah or darren aronofsky yeah
in like inventing him like an
oscar-winning performance where he plays
like a yes a dark like a recluse yeah
like like the i can see that yeah like
that would be brilliant who else could
do that like paul thomas anderson
somebody like like
five directors who could reinvent
that catherine bigelow yes yes yes
another and
many others many others not many others
yeah uh anyway back to adam carla
you know what's funny i thought
he talked so much about how much he
loves talking and doesn't you know he
really interesting stuff about the
working construction they wouldn't let
him talk not let him talk and he was so
itching to talk because he um he felt
lonely yeah he wanted to talk and i
thought for a guy who loves talking and
needs to be talking this much he doesn't
seem to love it that much but i'm sure
he does you know what i mean he's
like
he's not it doesn't seem like he doesn't
like talking i know you mean but there's
kind of a
he has a curmudgeonly vibe he does he
does he seems like the kind of guy who
would not mind being alone yes yeah but
yet he talked a lot about how he doesn't
like being alone well maybe he got in
over his head and now he's talking too
much he's talking more than he'd like
that's the that's the vibe he gives off
a little bit especially in the beginning
when he was like uh wait a minute are we
rolling
are we is this on are we doing it i
think that in his defense he just didn't
know the format exactly yeah and that's
what i realized that afterwards at the
time i thought it really threw me
actually he's used to when you're on his
show and i've seen him do it he sets it
up like it's it's a very traditional
okay i'm talking to
uh you know him from these movies and
from this and here he is it's justin
he sets it up i mean it's a very well
let me offer another we don't do that
potential explanation
he has been doing it so long
and is so comfortable talking
on the air
that there's not even a hint of
a performance in him
which might lead someone like me to
think
uh he's not in a mood to talk too much
or he's feeling a little
you know uh
like annoyed or something yeah but it
might just be he's so comfortable that
he's not putting much effort into it
because he's he doesn't need to because
he's so comfortable
just talking you know i also think i
didn't realize
this about him that uh
i don't know how to say this this might
be offensive but
but um
when he's when he was on the man show
i never really understood
how or where he got the man cred
to to host a show like the manchester i
didn't realize that story with jimmy
not not only that but that he was oh
yeah he was like a constructive
construction guy he was a carpenter he
was so cool not that only men can do
those things no but traditionally you
know working construction and boxing you
know uh being a boxing coach i didn't
realize he did all these traditional
man things that's true although
you know i sensed there were moments
like that where i sensed oh wait a
minute he's talking a lot about like
this is a man thing he's like he's
really like drawing a clear line between
men and women which is why i think i
brought up misty friedman because misty
was my boxing
i can't believe it's about to say my box
i had a boxing trainer at one point um
it's not gonna be good for your for her
business if you talk about that too much
oh i know but she tri sam she trained
rockwell she trained togo john togo she
trained really guys who were really good
at bikes and sam good at boxing really
good he is yeah and and bella heath go a
lot of like
you know some of the most famous boxers
bella heathcote and phoebe tonkin a lot
of um but both men and women but misty
and she had a very high where she talks
like this and she has a very demure kind
of way about her and the thing she's
done she's she can
i mean she can murder you with
me personally either of us do you think
she could definitely beat me up
oh
i just want to see how you react
i mean she's like the real deal she's
talking but he didn't know her he didn't
know her and so that i was like
but now i'm thinking like i wonder if
that's why i brought her up just to be
like you know what there are some really
uh anyway non-men yeah who are good
boxers yeah yeah who trains
uh-huh do you know who that is
and i don't want to define her because
of her father oh good catch yeah thank
you uh she is she does happen to have a
very famous sign but not the first thing
you should say about her i didn't say
that
don't shame me i know i'm shaming my
she's a great boss this is my instinct
my i'm shaming my instinct my instinct
was to say she's the daughter of
muhammad ali but she's a great boxer in
her own right and i should have led with
that which i did caught myself
i guess i don't need to be here anymore
yeah i'll see ya
um
uh yeah he he
but but that's i'm glad that we left it
in only because it was kind of
interesting i like what he said about it
yeah me too
he was like i think people like these
organic moments that's part of why
someone likes listening to the show yeah
i started because of these organic
moments right well they got plenty in
this show but i thought about what he
said that like you know in a given if
you go out to dinner with somebody i
mean it's got a first date though you
forget four or five of those moments you
have like 20 or 30 depends on the day i
know i know i know
uh yeah i mean i guess the goal is to
have as few as possible or is the goal
to like
on the heels of those moments like
to to be comfortable let's talk about a
date i think having zero of those
moments
is problematic having too many of those
moments is problematic in a different
way but i think you need
some of those moments in order to
establish chemistry yes do you think and
also to transition into a first kiss or
something well you remember keir's thing
that he read about that he i don't know
if he tried it once but our friend
before he got happily married here
either tried something or was really
fascinated by this thing where you go on
a date and you establish this beforehand
you say to the person you're gonna see
let's not let's not talk first date
first date yes never met this person
right so you established this through
text
let's when we meet up at dinner or
whatever let's not talk for 20 minutes
was it that long i think it was i
thought it was 10. it was whatever it
was 10 minutes in silence is a long
man and what was the point again just to
see if you have uh
just like the pheromones or whatever's
in the air that like that that
indefinable thing indefinable undefined
it also you know think about first dates
that you've been on where i mean i can
only imagine what you're like first god
oh man um where you talk a mile a minute
and you
and like you launch like you're so
embarrassed you don't want half a second
of dead error you just want to keep it
going keep going keep going but imagine
if
you
don't have the pressure of right away
having to launch into a conversation and
you can just exist in the space with
someone
even if it's five minutes yeah i think
that's a good idea for someone like you
i do too
five minutes because then you can
get some of the awkwardness out of the
way
you can make eye contact you can smile
you can look around you can kind of
experience the space with the person
before launching into conversation
i'm imagining doing it now and
it would be really hard i'm sure the
first
minute two couple minutes would be like
like me making like making faces and
stuff and like but eventually you'd stop
you'd run out of that you'd have to
settle in and then when you get to talk
it might be like
such a nice relief to be able to use
words
or would the whole time you would be
thinking what's the first day the thing
i'm going to say yeah and then you would
obsess over the first oh yeah like how
am i going to break this silence yeah
knowing me maybe you shouldn't it's very
hard to be
truly present with somebody i mean i
think that's why like
you know i'm thinking about
friends that i got to see in la and
shout out to my allie friends and
how how nice it was to see them because
i you know we've been in quarantine for
so long and it's nice to be
just comfortable and present with
someone i'm laughing because you don't
do shout outs right
you don't when you shout someone out you
either have to know their name or
you have to say a name you can't just
say shout out to my la friends like
that's that's not a shout out a shout
out is shouting out i don't think shout
out la shout out to my yellow friend you
can't say i don't know i mean i didn't
shout out all of ella what's a shout out
has to be a name out that you should
like our friend jerry o'connell uh-huh
we shouted him out i know a lot yeah too
much and you know what's funny about
jerry too he's a very good friend of the
show though he is he's like maybe a best
friend he's like a friend of me at the
show because he doesn't like to admit
that he listens
that's true but he does and um we
got into a thing lately where
he i i've talked about this on the show
where i noticed it's very embarrassing i
noticed that he doesn't like my
instagram photos so we sat with him at
dinner i called him out i was like jerry
what's going on
and he's like what what do you mean i
didn't any he said i was i don't think i
muted you and i didn't know that was a
thing you could do i did it again oh
[ __ ] uh yeah he denied it he denied it
which makes me think
but isn't he now liking your instagram
post not really he likes all of mine
he's a very supportive follower he
doesn't like i know i see him all over
whenever i see somebody's photo even
somebody people he doesn't know
i've seen him do it i've seen him scroll
through and go click click click click
i'm sure there are people listening to
this right now that are like
yeah you know come to think of it jerry
always likes my things i don't even know
him
anyway jerry when we got together with
him uh it was
it didn't feel like he hadn't hung out
with friends in a long time and i felt
the same it was like we were just
talking so much
yes it was a lot of
a lot of talking it's like adam carolla
at the end of a long work day when he
couldn't talk and then got to listen to
that's right that's right i really do
think it's
so cool that he can build stuff i am i
know so jealous of you you both have to
think it's cool that he can build stuff
i wish that i had those skills i really
do and i i fear that
i'm never going to be able to be someone
who can do that kind of stuff i thought
about it like i feel like i missed the
boat well there's a way to do i mean
youtube youtube videos i think that's
the way to do it there i thought about
it today because there are uh i have
these framed pictures everywhere that
i
they're just around the house i can't
put them up it's just so embarrassing to
admit that i can't what's the
alternative you just
uh
hired taskrabbit can't do that i i think
i'd i'll have to but i i the reason i
haven't done that yet is because
i
i know that i ca i'm capable of it i can
use a hammer i can use these tools
you're all so handy in other ways you're
handy with gardens
landscape stuff i can do i love doing
that stuff but when it comes to
precision you're not a precise person
right because i don't like to measure
and you need a ruler i used to hate that
stuff in geometry class oh [ __ ]
protractors and compasses i wrote
i also think it's cool that he
essentially broke into being a st comedy
star by
utilizing
these real world skills he had you know
like he that character that oh that
classic shop class teacher so he kind of
used i like that that he loves wood but
he hates kids yeah i had a shop class
teacher like that i never had shop class
which probably helps explain why i can't
decide
why didn't i take shop uh
i don't shop
i don't
i don't know you know what it is because
i took i think that we had the option
homack there was sewing there was
cooking and there was shop and i did i
love that class i did the sewing and the
cooking
but obviously i mean nothing against
sewing but
but shop right now would have been i
know so useful such a more uh much more
useful thing than sewing yeah how often
do i sew well to make you feel better uh
i don't remember learning any
obviously i don't remember learning
practical things like
i'm i i wonder if we did but here's how
to hang a picture for example or here's
how to build we didn't really build we i
remember like car carving
wood and then we'd carve up thing of
plastic sure you're not thinking of boy
scouts no no we carved um
i carved like a utah jazz thing and
played oh i remember that yeah that was
good
well yeah but like not very practical
like how are you going to apply that
skill to like well no but it shows that
you have the skills to use it's just
using machinery it's like using a vice
and like file but someone would say
hanging a picture frame is pretty easy
too yeah but if you know how to do it
pun intended i think you hit the nail on
the head when you talked about the uh
oh man if whoever's listening uh anymore
if anyone's listening
if you're watching 90 day fiance um
you'll really appreciate this joke
there's a character on it named zied who
is just very literal so when his
um
fiancee says
well what are you really going to go
home before you're going to
go home before ramadan and not marry me
and you go yes she'll ask incredulous
like uh
she'll be like wait are you telling me
that
i can't sleep in my own house during the
entire month of ramadan you want me to
go sleep at my mother's house come on
and you go yes
yeah he just is very
like placid and like a matter of fact he
is so he thought it'd be funny if he
said
you hid zine and zied because his name
is yet yeah
there you go
i bet a couple people laugh at that
uh anyway if you laughter that write in
uh so adam carla's book is called i'm
your emotional support animal navigating
our all woke no joke no joke culture
and uh i'd like to read it because the
topic i would too is of interest to me
we've come to have a
more sensitivity towards uh people from
different walks of life which i think is
a good thing overall i i think everyone
would agree with that but it's defining
what those rules are and what is
offensive and how much you can do and
you know i can't wait to read your book
hell
yeah uh i i would never be able to write
that book it's a tricky topic it is
let's read a letter okay great behind
you all right yeah
okay
their name is cam
barfield cam barfield cam
one name uh-huh i i'm guessing short for
cameron bar field
instead of garfield i bet i wonder if
they say that
it's like garfield with a b barfield
or a field of barf
probably not that cam barfield remember
jesse barfield no baseball player oh
that does sound familiar jesse maybe
that's why i don't think it's a weird
name because i associated with jessica
twins uh wait i think maybe twins yeah
just white sox i think maybe twins
uh-huh
cam barfield jesse barfield okay subject
is [ __ ] it and pull it it's so funny
shout out to jonah that's a shout out
yes it is you're getting better at shout
outs oh good
uh hey guys i know it's been many
episodes but i can't get cocket and pull
it out of my [ __ ] head sorry cam
i run several waffle houses in south
georgia cool and all of my associates
think i'm crazy because i just say it
out loud then curse myself for doing it
in short i hate you
this is a great i really i love this
letter also
that does get in your head
it's gonna be back in my head i know
it's well it's been in my head for over
20 for like 15 years i was there when i
uh when it happened when that fateful
day happened it doesn't help to give it
a melody but um i often hear it too [ __ ]
it and pull it
i'm going down down down
and mister i'm going down swingins
okay
would you rather
let's fall out boy right i think so is
it fall out boys or no well now they're
fallout men right would but would it be
singular it's not fallout boys boy
singer fall out boy yeah
fall out boy i wonder what that means
fall out boy
i don't know
what would your guess be uh was radio
simpson's character based on that or
vice versa oh
[Music]
it might have been based on that man and
fallout boy it might have been
huh i want to look it up all right
that's my guess okay good guess would
you here's back to cam barfield
who hates us
um
would you rather i kind of like i like
yeah yeah it's nice to get a hate letter
i mean yeah yeah
i don't know how to say it but
it's not a real hater i don't know it's
affectionate but actually like i don't
want to get more hate letters no no no
they're you know real hate letters yeah
no good back to cam barfield would you
rather [ __ ] it or pull it no i'm kidding
i'm kidding he says would you rather
only have food taste sour for the rest
of your life or never taste at all again
sour does that apply to drinks too
let's say it does yeah
well i think it's tricky because sour
can be really good exactly
sour patch kids sour apple lemonade but
you know it's bad sour milk oh man
but okay so you don't drink milk what
don't exactly
that's that's why i would say yes sour
sour because i would just avoid the
gross sour things like milk sour sushi
i would avoid that what do you eat sour
patch kids
okay you're gonna look great
i wouldn't only eat that
your insides because not everything
like would things that don't normally
have any sour potential be sour like
um
i don't know like a crap like a saltine
saltine sour saltine
and how sour i mean are there degrees is
it is it bad sour or good sour
yeah this is a tough one
i would say if it's if there are degrees
if some things are bad something i would
take this out i would too take the good
or the bad i wouldn't want no taste you
take them both and there you have
the facts of sour life
you don't both have to remember the
facts of life themes hung from your
childhood
uh
um
who was your favorite on facts of life
go
tewti yeah me too you both have only two
do the best on fashion life
yeah you know because blair i liked but
she was too
stuck up is that the end of the letter
i'm sorry anyway cam says thanks for the
laughs cam well thank you cam you gave
us some laughs too thanks cam uh i would
take the sour not sour even though
knowing my luck i everything i ate and
drank would taste like sour milk would
be terrible and i'd be wishing that i
had picked it no taste option i was just
thinking out cam works at uh waffle
houses in south georgia he says he he
runs several
uh
i'm gonna be there i'm gonna be in
arkansas soon
shooting cam hook it up yeah i'd be so
funny though i like waffle houses
i do too and they're everywhere oh my
god everywhere oh man that'd be so fun
to run into him uh thanks again to cam
and our distinguished guest adam carolla
i hope he continues to fill the airwaves
with his intelligent philosophical
godfrey desk funny voice yeah thank you
for um i mean i guess you didn't use
them for this episode and really thanks
to your ears for taking this in yeah we
appreciate it and if you'd like to write
in it's lifeasshort wondering.com
send us a letter and we'll talk to you
next week
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's not co-hosted or produced by
cam newton rather
christian
and megan monaco senior producer is
megan v monaco
senior producer is michelle miesch lans
audio engineer sergio enriquez and when
it comes to executive producing who gets
their hands on that this one one
marshall louie it's all done under a
company name wondering
[Music]
fancy outfit for the duel
so i walked in the room and who do i see
oh burr it's cold in here
turn the thermostat down now now you see
he's the guy who i want to please bird
it's still cold in here because i'm
drawing up the constitution i don't fear
whoa pretty good
that's not terrible it's not you know i
thought that you'd seen it because i
heard you rapping all the time doing the
songs
the year was
1776 i remember it like it was
yesterday
whoa sixth day you really are a reimster
so here i am i'm fighting with the
british
and i'm thinking to myself
a little swedish that's good that's good
you